[Music]
you really got it down you got
you really got me now gather sonic gets
back
[Music]
oh you comin
where
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
whoo van Halen comin at ya tuesday in
the morning how you feeling what a way
to start the week off right a little van
Halen feeling good this is steve
rannazzisi and hear me this book thanks
for coming back and joining me i hope
you had a good week I'm in a good mood
myself I go on vacation this week I'm
very excited about that could use a
little time at the beach as they say
relaxation it's been good I want to
start off by saying thank you to
everyone who came out this past weekend
to Buffalo New York to the fabulous
helium comedy club in Buffalo and there
was a busy weekend with the UFC in town
I thank you kindly for making a little
bit of time for your year old pal here
coming down the helium thank you to
Jessica Michelle singleton who made the
trek with me out there after coming back
she was in Africa for three weeks landed
at one o'clock in the afternoon last
Wednesday and then took the red-eye with
me at ten o'clock at night so thank you
to come for her for coming out she
crushed all weekend long and and Liam
who opened the show local comedian check
him out if you live up there he's a
really funny dude and Sean who runs the
club up there it's just I've been there
five times they've been open about five
years and I have a blast every time I go
I eat my weight in wings I get ridiculed
for every place I choose to eat the
wings at everything take a look physical
wing war happening up in Buffalo every
time I told someone oh I ate wings at
this place they're like oh that place
stinks you get to go to this place so
all i got was indigestion and bad looks
but it was fun thank you to the Buffalo
folk I took the first flight yesterday
Sunday back from Buffalo got back to LA
at ten-thirty and then drove straight
over to the All Things comedy studios to
to live call the Masters with my friend
court mccowan if you got a chance to
check it out thank you very much it was
a blast I know we didn't have the
largest viewership in the World Golf is
a very uh it's not the most popular
sport in America but court mcallen and I
had a real good time live calling it you
know we would just kind of did it along
with the play with it you know with the
with the CBS coverage and I know bill
and Bert Kreischer had done a couple of
those with football games so court and I
figured we'd give it a crack for the
final round of the masters and by the
way it was fantastic coming into it we
couldn't have asked for a better like
Sunday situation there were like 10 guys
that could win it and then we went to a
playoff between two top 15 players in
the world Sergio Garcia Justin Rose they
both kind of handed it to each other in
regulation and then we went to the
playoffs and Sergio sunk a birdie putt
which was unreal I'm happy for him I
didn't think he could do it but uh uh
yeah yeah I Sergio thank you to the
guest to to bill burr who called in from
Texas and yes for parnevik from Florida
I think Jonas blixt was down in Florida
too he called in Jason Gore stop by for
a couple for about an hour after playing
lakeside and shooting 265 and then came
over and joined us so thanks to everyone
who joined us and who watched we had a
really good time doing that and now I
get to go on vacation yeah to the beach
it's look it's vacate I'm looking
forward to it i always do we go to
usually take a week spring break pick a
beach go sit down the wife the kids but
you know it's it's it's we have a
schedule it's not like just we get to do
whatever we want we're up at seven the
kids are up at seven you go down to the
pool you drop your stuff off of your
chairs you claim your spots you know
like you lay out your newspapers and
your toys and stuff so everyone knows
hey these are these seats are taken then
you head over to breakfast you crush the
morning breakfast a couple pieces of
fruit perhaps a pastry to get a little
sugar rush going back up to the room you
know sunscreen bathing suits on then you
head down to the pool you're there all
day you're lunching at the pool
then daddy had to head back to the room
to go to the bathroom you know how I do
it bathroom break I go do some paperwork
wink wink yeah and then back to the pool
again hanging out dinner walk around the
grounds check out the beautiful sights
take some pictures pass out go to sleep
then I go off to the balcony and i watch
netflix and I stare at the water we do
that for seven days it's the best but I
mean in no way do I get to like just
sleep whenever I want and read 80 books
and you know none of that stuff I mean I
am going to bring a book though I'm
going to bring the hike I did order it
so that's the next one I'm going to get
on to that's the one that's got its
hooks into me so yeah next weekend I
leave for vacation the podcast will be
out next Tuesday don't fear I will drop
that podcast next week's guest I pretty
sure I know who it is but I don't say
till i 100% sure so but there will be a
podcast next week's for sure yeah I'm on
vacation for a week then I come back I
got some dates let's see where the dates
where's my calendar here it is Oh
Buffalo's done that was great we're
going to 0 earth day two 20-second but
also i'm an oklahoma oklahoma west
siloam springs at the casino me and Rick
Ingram coming in for one day I had a
great time last time looking forward to
again and then the 28th and 29th of
April in Columbus at the funny bone two
shows Friday to show saturday please i
love that city come check it out I got
some new stuff for you guys this is all
new you've seen it so come check me out
the 28th and 29th in columbus ohio oh
and then I wanted announced first week
in June I know it's a little bit away
but June well that's actually a second
weekend in June June eighth ninth and
tenth I met comics at Mohegan Sun in
Connecticut the Mohegan Sun Casino it's
humongous so they have a great comedy
club their comics and i will be there
jun 8 9 and 10 connecticut tri-state
area come on up it's it's summer almost
so you know you calm down your pre booze
at the pool the un's boots boots boots
boots boots boots and then you go down
you have a little dinner and then you
come check me out I comics and Mohegan
Sun yeah that's the 8th 9th and 10th in
June and yeah that's it that's all
that's what I got going on right now
let's talk about this week this week i
got my one of my best friends in the
world probably my best friend in los
angeles for sure i've known him since
pretty much the day I moved here his
name is Steve Simone we have been
roommates we have been coworkers he is
godfather to my second son he is a
family member he's my family he's one of
the kindest people know I wanted he's
the kindest person I know he truly is I
mean and my brother's a priest savona is
kinder than my brother my brother can be
a bit sharp can we say that pointed
Simone is just kind he's just a nice
person he gives more way more than he
ever gets and he is truly one of the
funniest story tellers and comedians
I've ever seen we have we started the
comedy store together 17 years ago I got
there he was there before me and we've
watched each other get better and get
worse and have breaks and have
disappointments and truly through all of
it he has never changed he's never
changed you know at all towards me and I
I you know I love him I really do Wow
Wow guys do you which has happened there
this is me telling another man that I
love them I love you Steve Simone and I
thank you for doing my podcast we chose
van halen because one of the things I
was thinking about so what I was think
about introducing Steve we went with
both tremendous van Halen fans he's from
Philadelphia I'm from obviously New York
and so we have similar sensibilities as
far as music and we grew up kind of the
same way Irish
Italian Catholic families and we both
love van Halen so when we got to LA
we're just probably put is a 2,000
probably 67 van Halen decided to get
back together David Lee Roth they're
going to go on tour and they wanted to
come to the Staples Center why not right
LA so we got tickets like the day they
came out Simone and I and my friend Mark
Ellis who's another tremendous van Halen
fan and an East Coast guy from DC so we
were like yeah we're going and so we the
data concert came we were like obviously
the concerts at eight we need to get
there at like three to pre booze and so
we've met at the comedy store parking
lot we drove over in my car to pre booze
at the Staples Center and when we got
there nobody was there no one not the
people that were to the staple center
not even the parking lot people not even
the guy that who's in charge of opening
the locks to open the gate to let people
into the parking lot we had a wait for
that guy to show up so we were truly the
first car inside of the parking lot and
we were there for about an hour before
anyone else showed up to the concert and
we were already drunk and had urinated
in seven to ten parking spaces around
our vicinity so now people the plots
filling up but no one is coming close to
us because we're like the discussing
people that I've obviously been living
there for a while so it's now like and
two hours of the concert we have gone
through all the food that we brought for
the pre-concert party we're almost
through the booze and now we're starving
and we can't we're not going to go
inside because you know no one's in
there everyone still out the parking lot
so we ordered pizza yeah we ordered
dominos or whatever one of those pizza
places to the parking lot of the staple
center I remember making the call that
guys like where are you I'm like this
staple center he's like what I'm like
what's he's like what's the address i'm
like lot d and i'm guy i got to give him
credit normally they would have just
hung up but for some reason i got the
right guy over at dominos or wherever
the hell i was calling because he was
with me he's like all right I've never
delivered to a parking lot before but
and they did it he called me when he's
outside la ti ran outside
pick them up gave a nice little tip and
then before you know it we had two
pizzas and now everyone was around us
because now we're the guys with pizza
who is who has the balls to order pizza
at a tailgate party we do and it was
great we destroyed the pizza we had to
carry our friend Mark Ellis into the
concert because I mean the reason why
everyone's getting so drunk is because
you know Van Halen's such a volatile
band you never know when they going to
break up so we were pretty much
convinced we were 5050 that they were to
break up while we were in the parking
lot partying so but fortunately we went
in we had an unbelievable time that
concert was ridiculous we had like
basically it was Simone and I our friend
Mark was so drunk we were it was like
weekend at Bernie's we were just kind of
holding him up so that he can like say
that he was there he was annihilated and
uh yeah man this is like one of a
thousand stories I could have told I
probably should have picked a better one
but I I love this guy he picked the book
the comedy writer by Peter Farrelly
which is written in 99 I heard about it
beforehand but I didn't wasn't on my
radar so this is a fun talk because it's
very it's us it's an East Coast is about
an East Coast guy that moves to LA to
pursue comedy and he wants specifically
to be a screenwriter so this is this is
very close to home for Steve and I I
hope you enjoy this podcast this is
Steve Simone with the comedy writer
[Music]
[Applause]
you give re set the levels no I change
it every time Dave Taylor did yesterday
a little bit I'm he said you should do
it and change it just because different
people speak yes yeah but you know what
just league him running through level
later or other programs where it just
evens everything out oh really mm-hmm he
seems nice i spoke well yeah quickly on
the phone and then we're gonna get rid
of talk yeah he's the sweetest he does
all my grown-up stuff and he produces
Joey's podcast too yeah I see him on it
this Joey of his own studio yes nice
that's the clean ice and then callinan
shabb got their own studio fighter and
the kid have their own city I mean it
looks like it every time I see it
there's like I've I mean it looks like a
yes well a proper studio like a wood
background and well you can use the
studio at The Comedy Store you can use
the all things calm all things comedies
got a nice one I've done punch-drunk
there yeah me I haven't done punch-drunk
that but I did Tripoli and the
International bad boy with him and
Randolph tremendous my Kostas podcast oh
the birth day one yeah yeah that's the
other thing it's like I really haven't
done a lot of other ones so have you
done the crab feast did crab feast once
had a great time under those guys are
great Ari's great I just did Brody's
done Ari's before she rodeos okay
haven't done Josh wolf you did
birthright did Bert's that's how the
whole thing started on dirt yeah birth
is great because yeah we get drunk and I
was a fun one yeah I haven't done a lot
of those so be fun to do those but this
this podcast is here me this book that
is the name of my podcast with Steve
Rannazzisi I'm your host and today I'm
with Steve Simone who happens to be a
not only a talented entertainer but one
of my best friend in the world oh god
father to my second son and and I love
you buddy tiny little baby here well
thanks for being on him and it's always
weird when we have to talk in two
microphones to each other yeah it's fun
we've done it I've done your podcast
Steve also is a very great podcast of
very great podcast as our president
elect would say called good times with
Steve Simone so I've done that a couple
times but it's weird when we talk in two
microphones because usually we'd note do
that yeah but you know what after a
while you forget you're talking like our
phones and the best thing about podcast
is when you just start talking and you
forget that you're being recorded like
the other night I did The Comedy Store
podcast with Eleanor and Ingram yeah I
did that one to that yes so fun right
yeah it's in the basement yes in the
basement as a store but you start
talking you forget like and I didn't say
anything mean but I think I might owe
Lucas an apology did I feel terrible
well why because we told you told
stories no it's a bit we were talking
about you know how people always say
they killed they killed and never what
Mike black said that one time we would
find Lucas in the main room with the
noose around this next and they'll say I
kill that myself yeah but I just told
that story like just a leica in the
middle I was like no no you remember
what they said and now I don't want
Lucas to think I was making fun of
course not okay look you happen to be a
tremendous person so your level of
kindness is much higher than everyone
else's especially in the environment and
atmosphere that we live in the comedy
scene so everyone will absolutely it's
at the base level look at it as a joke
and and it was a joke ya know what
wanting it to be mean or even a joke i
was just like remember when they said
this about Jason I wasn't like now the
fact that it's so funny is because it's
so true we could pop we could definitely
see that happening right like that would
be something that could definitely for a
long period of our lives that we knew
Jason we wouldn't be surprised if he had
hung himself okay name and dot dot
myself as a joke to you know to go out
like that because you know those were
some rough years for Jason for all of us
for everyone involved I've been watching
paying the brother time it's so good oh
my gosh think our years at The Comedy
Store or like our version of that you
know we went through that and I think
that's the best thing about life is the
dark times somehow make you a better
person and more appreciative of the good
stuff
it forges relationships that success
couldn't I really do believe that like
think about the stuff we went through at
The Comedy Store yeah that just thats
night one Mitzi dressed us down with
Pauly like that was we had monumental
yeah we had many of those nights those
are painful nights but I remember
laughing I mean what would had it be was
at 23 hours later yeah I mean we started
gambling 23 hours later ya naari so the
little cheat card for blackjack
blackjack we break and we want a little
bit of money I think and we're gonna
stay at that [__] hotel yep all three of
us in one room yes and instead we were
like [__] it we're driving home and I
remember we had the only way we would
have made that drive is if we started
laughing and we must have started
laughing and tell me yeah because I
great that was the only thing that we
could do but I don't know I talked to
David we've a little bit when he was on
the podcast about the friendships that
we made and that we have are the best
and they're solid and they're the reason
why most people now whatever level were
at in our lives or careers that we are
still able to break each other's balls
that's why i'm saying i don't think you
need to worry about Jason at all okay
cool yeah cuz I love that guy I love I
mean yeah um you uh you're gonna do a
book called words are called it's called
the comedy writer the comedy writer ever
hear of it no written by peter farrelly
of the Farrelly Brothers well let me ask
you a question are you a book reader
would you consider yourself a book yes
but this okay non fiction nonfiction I
read primarily biographies biography
enjoyed or stuff like about theology and
like religion I like to like read stuff
about military like wait do you buy
military now because I know you a little
bit may just interject yeah military
like history military stuff or like
conspiracy military no spear like dark
forces stuff like no no no not nerd
science fiction stuff I like to listen
to that on the radio that alike got it
that's like my guilty pleasure but books
like on you know guys at
went through the Navy SEAL selection
process or the Delta Force selection
process or those sort of books or like
sort of like self-help books like
there's one in there it's called like
the superior reminder something at some
Navy SEAL wrote oh my god like that's
interesting okay or like there's a book
I have five I I feel like those are dead
sometimes I was like kind of like here's
how i do my life and almost like a do
you have to read those couple times
before absolutely are breaking it down
like I read how to get things done that
book yes and it's so dense but once you
learn it it's a great system to use but
to be able to get it it's like I'm going
constantly getting rereading up the
intellect to it dumb do I not look and
yeah the answer is yes that's why I have
to go back and reshoot some people just
want something yet no no yeah I have to
go back over and over again and like a
lot of that stuff it's not fun to read
it's like because it's so dense you're
like ah but there's very little fiction
I read because I'm like I think real
life's way better than fiction yeah but
then I didn't want to do a book that was
nonfiction I don't want to like you know
tell you about a book i read about st.
Ignatius or something because I'd be
boring I'm gonna do podcasts up with my
brother yeah that would be amazing yeah
i would highly recommend my cuz I'm sure
not gonna force him to do the Bible but
if you wanted to that'd be a fun one
would be so quick wow that was my eyes
went to cath of school we might at least
essentially learned the entire Bible
we've learned the first the Old
Testament in seventh grade like
beginning to end awesome and then in
eighth grade we learned the New
Testament like just broke it down by
each author you know and so it was sort
of I felt like we had but I mean first
of all I don't remember half the stuff
I've read in eighth grade let alone the
Bible stuff which was like that's the
least of I have to hold on to you know
like math is like number one so I don't
think I really read any book
until I really got out of college yeah
that's why the how this started and then
the only thing I could amend to what you
just said is I've never didn't start
after out of college I never saw like
the last book that i really like i like
you said autobiographies i read already
Lange's book i read like people that I
enjoys lives I would read there by red
howard stern's book like so yeah that's
what got me started because it was like
that Tony Robbins principal he goes
success leaves clues and I remember when
I was a young comedy nerd I was like how
do people do this mm-hmm like how did
John Candy become John Candy how did Jim
Carrey become Jim Carrey so if there was
a book on those guys I would read it
like there's a great book on Sam Kinison
that his brother wrote Sam it's amazing
i just read nor McDonald's book ah i
right color that we're broadening on
adam oh the entire thing I just tweeted
Adam I was like a treated enormously
congratulations on the book and finally
someone pointed a light at this useless
dolt Adam heated he's hilarious imeem
know the thing that I love about norm is
that it's not just an autobiography
here's how it happened this is a funny
story and it's a it is a narrative he's
telling a story to someone else so it's
almost you know I feel like I'm reading
like a real book not just someone's like
I took you know for the most part by
autobiographies are a little bit easier
read you just get through this was kind
of a fun more challenging of a read well
that's what the comedy writer is it's a
novelization I think it's loosely based
on what actually happened to Peter
Farrelly okay when he got to Hollywood
which is all this is peter farrelly of
the Farrelly Brothers good like some of
my favorite filmmakers of all time and
remember my buddy albarino yeah from he
read the book back in like 97 I haven't
read this book it's almost been 20 years
it has to be soon i don't think i read
it since 99 when was it written do you
know i think it was written in 96 and 97
okay not maybe 98 their success like it
was right in the middle of that runt
like I think about Mary dumb and dumber
yeah kington yep and there's something
about mary
think anybody's had three home runs like
that in a row hello anybody no no I'm
just know like three they you if you
said they were the three funniest movies
of all time I go I'm even forget
directors I'm just thinking actors like
three good funny performances in a row
like bam bam bam killed it kill ya so
this is the so Peter today because I
only asked as I know that mark Duplass
and Jay Duplass are writing a book but
they're doing it together hmm i wonder
if is this something that the Farrelly
Brothers or just Peter is this is that's
what he's almost yes was just Peters
thing yeah and I think what his deal was
I think he got like an MFA in creative
writing or something like that and was
probably one of those guys just loved to
write and loved movies as well but this
was brought I don't know but this was
probably I know this was the second
novel he wrote the first one was outside
Providence and they did make that one
into a film I don't know why they make
this into a film or series that's great
really yeah it's really really funny so
tell me about it okay so this is the
book that inspired me to read does that
make sense okay it just came into my
life at the right time was it albarino
that told you to do it yeah he read it
he bought it by the way he's he's a he's
a winning God at a at the San Francisco
49ers yes game ax game field access yet
that was a fun day the best yeah shout
out to to him as a hobby and thank you
for introducing this book with a big
jack I know what that means yeah he's a
he's a great dude yeah so I guess that's
a positive person to be like hey you're
looking at this is something you should
do this is a field that you're in but
it's not like I how to I remember him
giving me this book he he was on a
business trip he bought it at the
airport read it on the plane it's a
quick read and he was like oh my god he
goes this dude in the book is you I go
what it was this fictional characters
you you have to read this and I go I
don't want to read a book and he goes
it's written by the Farrelly Brothers I
was like what they make movies and right
but I grab that hand yeah but I would
think like what is this their JV project
like look at the great movies they make
like what a the other sot like while
they're eating lunch directing these
movies that they write down these books
look if it was really good we creativity
do you have we would all hear about it
it'd be called a movie that's already
I'd be like okay we'll say but yeah
that's the thing getting past that
you're like I would I gotta dive into
this so Kiowa for me like I'm like a
six-year-old or it's like I don't want
to read it in somebody's like well
Chewbacca's in it I might give me the
book don't you get tired though sleepy
like as soon as I dig in I get so sleepy
most books I do well let's not give her
like numb really night night and then
limited because people look like in the
end the bear said to the men men men men
Linden I remember in seventh grade mr.
Brewster was like our gym teacher and
like health do you guys have a health
class where they liked each about
nutrition and yeah yeah and like say no
to drugs he was tremendous he was like a
fit version of Buddy Garrity it was just
such a jock and it was like I tell you
if he can't get to sleep because i just
opened a book and it's like that's how I
feel too that's how I mean I brought my
mom would read books growing up she'd
read like romance and almost like those
paperbacks when I was a kid I couldn't
understand why people wanted to read I'm
like it's so boring yeah because we got
like a signed books and and then I was
dyslexic that was look that was the
whole pradhan realize that until I was
like 38 years old wait how did you find
out because I was like why did it's
reading stock yeah and I took me so long
to like learn how to read and like I was
I would say I would always pay attention
in English class yeah and I would just
pay attention so much that I didn't mean
to read the book I'd memorized
everything what people were saying yes
and then I get the cliff notes knock it
out the day before the test and I was
good
but then I didn't realize I was my buddy
Cory that helped me realize I was
dyslexic he was asked me questions you
sure you're not dyslexic I'm like yes
there's like if you ever taken a test
and I went online and I was like ding
ding ding ding I know I'm gonna do it
yeah could very well be highly creative
people really yep there's a correlation
dyslexia com yeah there's Yale has a I
think it's like Yale dyslexia whatever
they have great online tests and it's
not a hundred percent accurate so but
who knows I think there might be
something to it um so yeah I mean
breedings not was not a passion of yours
like now not just pretty fun you
wouldn't just sit down and plow through
a book no but that thing you've ever
into because of this book yeah this book
I was like oh okay and then uh the only
book I had actually read that was
fiction and enjoyed prior to this was
catcher in the rye love that book see I
never read that it's a really good book
I think you would enjoy it yeah and then
this this book sort of like it got me go
okay and then I just started to figure
out other stuff I was interested in and
most of the stuff like I said it's you
know nonfiction I like I like that stuff
but this just this book The Comedy order
came into my life at the exact time I
needed it does that make sense and it
tells the story of a guy from Boston who
hates his job as a salesman and whose
girlfriends who he was madly in love
with breaks his heart out of the blue
just out of the blue she was like you
know what I don't love you and he's like
I don't understand why like it why did
this happen you see like a slob is he
like a no he's like got his life
together but he's you know he doesn't
like his job and like I was like yeah I
could totally relate he was from Boston
I was really really and he decides he's
got nothing left to lose so he's just
going to move to LA and in his crazy
writer brain he's like I'm gonna finish
this script he started to write a movie
in Boston of how I want her back because
there's a movie about his relationship
with this girl so he arrives in LA with
a broken heart and a screenplay and then
all chaos just this city just eats him
up so he comes to LA
with like I'm coming off of this bad
breakup yeah here's how I can basically
get my feelings out on paper yes you
know let's just see how this thing turns
out yeah he's convinced that he's going
to tell this movie and that's it and
then she's going to actually fall in
love with him because he's like a rich
and famous screenwriter which is
something that I was like yeah that's
exactly what I'm gonna do I like that so
eastcote he's never been to LA before
this now all brand-new falls out of
water fish out of water exactly okay hey
would you say like that's the first
third of the book the breakup and
everything and now I know la this is
like 20 fact like page one well done
done he's arriving in LA and it's and
I'd like I said I haven't read this in
20 years but what I remember the first
significant seen that I remember is him
talking about the weather in LA and how
it technically wasn't summertime but it
feels like summer and it reminded him of
the summer so gives him like he wants
ice cream so he goes to baskin-robbins
write comedy ice cream la I'm in right
away and as he's walking across the
parking lot into baskin-robbins there's
a little person walking by and he's just
in a good mood and he like smiles at the
little person like a buddy and then in
his crazy writer brainy it's like that
guy sink said I'm content sending him
that I'm like hey you want some ice
cream little guy and it just plants a
seed in his head you know what I mean
like what about neurotics yeah the
neurotic seat they need to be a comedy
writer correct yeah exactly so then I
just remember he has the ice cream just
like his first day in LA or something
like that and then there's like a
commotion this is so great cuz I gotta
go back and reread this book and clean
honest hit in the book but that's the
best part and then there's a Death Star
now that's Star Wars yeah and that's the
best part Alec Reed show example right
later on like like you you you didn't
even that's not even like people wrote
about Ari like that that's not even
really how the book was it already did
the road by jack kerouac no I don't
remember the author again it was done it
was like a movie like 20 years ago no
it's about like going to pop apocalyptic
mmm father and son walking down a road
and dark dark you know but like back it
goes back and forth in time and like he
messed up some stuff what do people yeah
but I know but and people were loving it
that's the best part okay there is that
I don't really remember like what I was
going to ask you was by the way before
uh when you you said when you got to LA
or when you get to LA always feels like
summer time it feels good yeah I
remember I moved to LA in November like
wow November and the exact feeling of
warmth and being like wait is this
summer still happening yet what time a
year did you move to LA I moved out I
first moved I drove across country like
mid august i crashed on my buddy's couch
got a job at the slice the pizza place
found an apartment one in santa monica
yep does a good place the best found an
apartment went home to see my niece get
born and then came out officially the
first weekend football first weekend to
the NFL I remember landing at the
airport one of my Eagles buddies picked
me up at the airport we went to a bar to
go watch the game and I'm not gonna be
yeah exactly oh yeah that it was like
extended summer vacation when I first
got it took me years love living out
here to really notice a difference in
seasons I know that sounds crazy but I
was like even now it's 65 degrees and
everybody thinks it's freezing I know
it's amazing I saw people last night the
movie theater all bundled up and like
they were in like I don't even know what
those they look like Native American
like tarps with like holes in the middle
yeah just did Drake them over themselves
like it's fridge I was in Canada less
because minus 10 yeah it look like
Eskimos please get him back to what we
said about I can cold weather and tough
times just makes better people well just
leave it at that yeah make really
weren't hardened to people but they're
more down to earth yes
the people in Canada are so nice there
yeah they appreciate things more I think
absolutely that's why it with this book
it's the East Coast mentality coming
over to the west coast and I'm not
saying people that grew up on the west
coast but your pop usually genuinely
more positive people yes because the you
know the weather's nicer and
everything's sort of a bit like and you
know it's great i remember a line from
the book it's so funny how you can just
jostle things so his job was he was a
Salesman you know those big commercial
ships that like you can like go between
here in Europe he sold a car all those
containers yes he sold cargo space out
of Boston now all the other ships would
start in Florida go all the way up and
by the time they reach Boston go over to
Europe he's a salesman for the only ship
liner that starts a boss and it goes all
the way down so he said his whole job
was just taking people out and getting
them drunk and like trying to be like
come on man we're the only American
company that does this and I remember
there was a line in there somewhere
about how the company hired all the kids
that graduated from Catholic schools
better act like dealing with guilt or so
like that and they were like better at
taking orders and like putting up a [__]
essentially that was in the book
somewhere so here's the guy who's like
as his heart broke and he's got nothing
left to lose shows up in LA and it's
still summer he's got to go get ice
cream and he's in a good mood and then
he sees a little guy and his crazy right
or brain he's like I don't want this
person to think I was making fun of them
because they're a little person he's
like I'm just happy cuz it's still
summer and I'm gonna have ice cream and
now he feels bad and I don't even think
he can enjoy his ice cream what I think
happened what does he become does he
have like easiest stand-up is it what
world does he want to get into no there
I fightin want to come someone wants to
be a comedy screenwriter okay and there
was a line in there that just had
resonated with me I remember he said
something about
how when he was a kid movies would make
him feel a certain way and they would
inspire him but lately it inspired him
to be a writer even more when he meant
when he watched movies that he was like
weren't that good and he's like you know
what I think I could really do that and
I remember having those feelings and
those thoughts like yeah like why not
like I was so broken by the time I was
like 27 28 I was like I have nothing
left to lose and that's sort of like
where this character is too how old is
he he's like 27 he I think in this book
in the book novelizations like yes late
20s is when I would assume and shows up
as no money gets the ice cream and then
the first significant event in the book
and I may be wrong is that there's a
woman on the on a building that's going
to commit suicide and I do it do it do
is you [__] piece of [__] you weak
piece of [__] I don't think what happens
is he he does try to convince it like he
tries to help and she does it anyway I
think that's what I'm oh really I think
so I like I said hammer at this
Antonio's but I think there was a line
where he was I called meet you halfway
Simone she flies it's saying super it's
Narnia yeah it's it's a science fiction
book she flies although even I can flat
just how crazy Simone in his dark brain
I thought this woman committed suicide
but in her book she's she's a difficult
creature that just brings joy to
everybody interpretations are very
different and dark yeah so I think that
was I saw tried to talk her out of it
yeah and she was like half ways i hear
enough anymore bingo yeah well any other
buildings yep then he's like really
welcome to LA and then it gets sadder
from there like he's trying to get a job
and nobody's read and he's trying to
finish his script and he's trying to
meet chicks
and then there's like this super easy
there's this super hot chick that lives
in his building was like an actress and
he was like oh it's on and she comes
over one night and I remember there was
a story hitting there we're like he
thinks he's gonna hook up with her and
he has whatever little money he has he
like goes and gets brownies and act like
he made the brownies because she came
already grab something to eat once so
now he wants to smell brownies so he's
like warming other he a store-bought
brownie to try to get it show up so then
the guy that bangs or shows up and takes
the wrong but you're having a Brioni for
Cheryl he's got no money I just know
crowded right I'm like I so relate to
this character second close that is when
yeah this is exactly me immediately so
then that guy becomes one of his best
friends who the guy that [__] up yeah
to check that he eat things like I guess
I'll hang out with you have already
emasculated exactly and that guys like
an actor who changes his name is
something Jewish because he thinks it'll
help him book parts not a bad idea by
the way for those of you looking to get
out here let's get a head start
leibowitz so good one to go with
couldn't hurt so then I'm trying to
remember what happens what I think
happens is he's working like in a
restaurant cleaning pots and pans like
getting his balls broken not getting any
chicks trying to finish this how I want
her back script uh and he's at the end
of his rope you know I think what
happens is much like Jason Lucas nah
he's at the end of his rope and what I
thought was really cool is that this guy
does have a religious side to him like
no matter what happened in his life he
used to say the same prayer every night
before I went to sleep so he was very
religious um he definitely has a
relationship with God got it okay and
that was another aspect to the
protagonists that I related to
but he was at a point after being in LA
for a couple months where he's like I
don't know if I believe anymore he was
like the world so awful my life so awful
I'm just trying to use the gifts that
you've given me I just want to try to
get this girl back I need a sign and
he's like God I just need a sign and
then there's a knock at the door and
it's the little person that he saw on
his first day in LA I'm the ice cream
from the ice cream yeah see the landlord
better he had been interviewed about the
girl jumping and there was somebody
keeps on calling his voice machine fully
smell I think it is he doesn't notice
and it's a little person the little
person I dated the woman that jumped off
the building she wait that was her
boyfriend yes present-day boyfriend yes
so that's that's his sign from God he's
volatile person so I'm like oh this book
i'm already in love right now I'm like
this is the perfect yeah he knows he
can't walk away from this and just right
so the Lord works in mysterious ways so
then he becomes friends with this guy
then the girls got a crazy sister that
moves in with them that ruins his life
completely like she winds up like almost
burning the house down and he can't kick
her out because it's a dead girl's
sister and he feels bad then everybody
thinks he's in love with her and he's
like I can't be this nice anymore she's
ruining my life he bullshits himself
into getting a lid and the guys like I
don't know if you can write but you can
[__] and that's what this whole
business is don't worry about anything
else this whole business operates off of
fear people are making crazy decisions
they'll give you a deal just because
they're afraid you might turn into
something so it's all this cool inside
stuff about Hollywood and then his
kindness to this woman winds up blowing
up in his face because this is what
happened ok so now I'll take the third
act of the book no I understand can I
ask you a question will you remember it
or should I cut you off here i'll go
ahead as one of the most kind people i
know yes have you ever been so kind to
someone that they then i don't wanna say
took it but they like thought that you
not sell in love with you but I kind of
like what my brother goes through where
they become infatuated with you and you
have to dial down your kindness towards
them or back off your relationship with
them to understand I'm saying understand
has anyone ever misunderstood your
kindness for some sort of like all
material motive I don't think so I don't
believe so I think everybody just knows
I'm so nice to everybody does that make
sense yeah that nobody I don't think so
and I don't think I've either you never
had a dial down your look I just can't
be nice this person anymore because they
take advantage of it or autumn well I
will say this trying to think no I don't
think I've no well I mean now I think no
be fair a kind person probably wouldn't
be able to do that but I'm sure you felt
like you've had your like AHA [__] all
there were times with like living with
fat change for example or I'm like I'm I
can't take this anymore yeah but you
drank back then it was different you
hadn't you had another place we all we
drank heavily back then yeah and that's
how we got through it too yeah otherwise
forget it yeah but yes it was the cool
thing about this book is there's a lot
of parallels between what he was going
through what we went through at the
comedy store okay during those crate
like dude I was like crazy so when
something that he wrote you were you
were able to go oh I don't know exactly
but I know that so I were educated dream
for moving to LA got it I read this this
is the book that inspired me not only to
read but it also inspired me to move to
LA and I was like I'll tell you a crazy
story and you know what I don't know
fool I'll tell you at the end of that
but it's quick like so many crazy things
with this book but it's cool anyway so
now this is agent is saying I don't know
if you can write but you're right it
hooks him up with a producer mm-hmm
who's like a shady Hollywood producer
who likes one of his ideas I don't think
it's the how I want her back script it's
a another to another idea that he had a
different pitch yeah he had a pitch
about an ice cream man but it's over our
movie okay like about all everybody
trusts the ice cream truck guy little
person who ice cream trucks out that has
nothing to do with the little person
that guy the little person becomes his
best friends and like sort of helps him
through the darkness and they sort of
help each other out they become best
buddies and then what happens is the
crazy girl that he lets live with him
for free sort of just ruins his life and
then he has a meeting set up with this
shady producer he was leaving the studio
sees the producer cause a car accident
he sees the producer cause a car cause a
car a smashing to someone else yeah like
some some poor people and it was clearly
wasn't their fault the guy's such a jerk
off it was like Henry you saw what
happened you know what's all their fault
and now he's had he's like like a
third-act dilemma or it's like he could
have all of his dreams come true he
could sell his movie he could be in
business with this jerk off but he sort
of has to lie yeah and he has to punish
people that are already suffering yeah
and he goes you know I forget it's not
worth it he's like now not worth it gave
that money Sam comes later no he
definitely wasn't the right thing he
does the right thing but the crazy girl
he lives with why think she's helping
him and winds up giving his script to
the shady producer who just rips it off
oh great and doesn't pay him at all so
that's his breaking point where he just
says oh so not only okay so he says you
know what I'm gonna do the right thing
obviously this is the he wasn't at fault
in the accident it doesn't get the deal
he said the crazy lady they living with
goes I'm gonna help them out yeah here
you know the script is great that
[__] guy takes the script and
produces it makes it without him craving
him no credit yes
and like she ruins it she almost
Bernstein's apartment she gets him
arrested she's a crazy person is she
crazy in the sense that she cares for
him and she just doesn't know how to
deal with it or is she like a legitimate
like that's [__] ball wheels off the
rails that's why I could work so well
written we're there Henry even has
friends that think they're in love with
each other and they're like this is what
relationships are and he's like no
you're nuts I'm just trying to be nice
to this person and this is what I get
for being the nice guy the world just
poops on your face yeah so the cool
thing about the book is he comes to this
realization that everything that he was
looking for in Los Angeles he doesn't
need he came from a great family he
loves boston and he was like i just want
to move back to a city or i can meet a
beautiful woman that isn't automatically
an actress and i can meet a woman that's
going to let me treat her great and he
was like if i sell a movie great if I
don't tell a movie the important thing
is I have my family my friends and my
Red Sox essentially and I was like okay
this is nice little book that's I and
look as a person who's you know gotten
some success and been on a television
show for a while you know people look at
success and go well what is your level
of success whereas are you to me
happiness is just being able to do the
things that I enjoy doing which is
telling jokes hanging out with my
friends hanging out my family you know I
don't know what their I don't know what
it takes to get that private jet money
all right if you have to just keep doing
every killing everything yeah and it
might and it probably does and that's
why there are some people that get there
I just don't know what I would have to
do to not get there and to me that
sounds lovely his idea of what would
make him happy yeah sounds lovely it
doesn't sound like giving up to me it
doesn't sound like no I don't know you
know becoming complacent or whatever
just better life like I and eat
yeah so it's a ballast yeah like I moved
out here to sort of the joke I wrote was
people moved to LA to prove that they're
special and I definitely must have had
those insecurities or sadness like I
moved here after girl broke my heart you
know what I mean and I did want to prove
that I was special and I did want to win
her back in a lot of ways I want her to
be like when I'm rich and famous you'll
see and it took me a long time to
realize that when people said famous
they meant lovable mm-hmm and it took me
a long time to get comfortable in my own
skin and to have a real relationship
with God where I wasn't just obeying
rules but it was like more of a more at
ease more more I felt more loved you
know what I mean to like the way I was
raised with religion not intentionally
but it's like I always felt like I had
to be on my best behavior instead of
just accepted where I was and this crazy
City that values everything that I don't
it values money and power and pride and
ego but in Los Angeles I think I've
really figured out how to live where I'm
like out it is our family and friends
and this like dude I'm just so happy I
don't even I haven't thought about this
book in 15 years but you're like I have
this new podcast let's get meatball
sandwiches and let's talk about a book
this is you did you never reread it I
did reread it when I when I first got
down a lamber feel like you're like uh I
gotta reread that or like feeling back
again like almost like an old yes you
know my dad gave me great advice many
years ago when I was in high school the
only book I read was catcher in the rye
and he was like pick a book and read it
throughout your lifetime yeah and he was
like because the book doesn't change
what you do and you're going to get more
out of it and you're going to find
yourself relating to different
characters in different plot lines in
the book will change over time as you
change so it's probably been like four
years since I read Catcher in the Rye
I'm going to go back and reread that and
then this comedy writer book now that
I've finished my first screenplay now
that uh in many ways like we're living
it you know like we're part of the
comedy store the greatest comedy club in
the world you're famous Ari's famous the
guy
said i starved with when I was rereading
this book 15 years ago 12 years ago or
different people now so it's going to be
really interesting for me to go back and
see if any of those plot points I
thought were in there really are you uh
well do you remember what's his sense of
is it funny like did you remember
laughing a lot in it is it yeah written
or is it more like character care the
way he tells a story is funny the way he
has it out and there are some funny
lines and yeah but not like a like a
joke joke joke joke no machine no the
situations are funny and for me so there
couldn't be a protagonist that I related
to more about like this good guy trying
his best in a crazy world and then
finding his making his peace with this
crazy world that make sense like he
thought this girl was going to bring him
this piece yeah but somehow he sort of
finds his own piece I wonder if it's it
did you feel any sense of like his
movies in it at all like what this guy
you know most of his movies have like a
somewhat of a normal person walking
around dealing with crazy abnormal
situations was it as like heightened
isms like you know hitting his the
fairly brother movies have crazy
character actors like with extreme
circumstance yes what the same sort of
formulas at play here where you have a
very very likable protagonist uh-huh a
very likable everyman very much like ben
stiller's character character from
there's something about mary and i
remember years ago like I this book came
into my life because I am a comedy know
right and I remember years ago listening
to NPR this is back in my early 20s when
I still didn't think it was possible
that you could leave Philadelphia to try
to work in show business I mean this
book gave me permission to dream like
that you know it ends terrifically for
him I'm like let me try yet I said maybe
whoa I I don't know maybe he feels that
or the protagonist or the you know
whatever Henry they had Henry hotline
yeah Henry feels as though giving up or
failure is but it's not it's not the day
just paint Los Angeles has a dark place
kind of
but it was still like it still
encouraged me I'm like yeah this guy can
do it I can do it but what I will say is
this it's similar to their movies in the
sense that you have a very likable
protagonist surrounded by all these
crazy people and it's very similar to
like ben stiller's character and there's
something about mary that's sort of do
you ever read dark books like books that
are you know are going to be sad no I
don't like sad no I like inspirational
and and that doesn't mean as yours a
obstacles okay yes my favorite books
like I said are on like there's this guy
Richard Marcinko who founded SEAL Team
six who wrote a book twenty years ago
called Rogue Warrior it's amazing
there's another book I forget Oh Colonel
wrote it about the formation of yet
Delta Force but but so so obstacles
would be with me mean like okay there's
something to get overcome but there is
you do overcome it yeah I couldn't read
a book where it's like I'm going to
overcome it and it just keeps getting
worse and worse and worse and may not
end yeah I don't think I don't want to
read something like that I know I have
friends at like love those books that
are just like I think there's enough
sadness in the world I like something
like even this made me feel better about
life I like something makes me feel
better mm-hmm and like if you go we
could actually can go look at my
bookshelf but i'm pretty sure the
majority of my books were about god i'd
have to move well we first we'd have to
move the action figures ever it's God
military pro wrestling all fun stuff did
the comedy writer ever write for leno
endeavor in the block block to be i'll
take a break to work for leno oh there
is never Dorian there where they pitch
Seinfeld stories design felled to Larry
David and a really cool anecdote in
there where he's on set he plays
basketball with the cast that years
there's some really cool fun stuff like
that so is it sort of like he gets a
little during his trip through LA he
gets a little fun it's like a little
forest gump e where he gets like yes
kind of put into these strange
situations where yes and I think in real
life I'm not certain but I think in real
life they appear fairly did pitch that
legendary virgin episode of Seinfeld and
I got a story by credit oh really I
think so yeah look if I can check that
will go I'm getting a fact checker on
this are you really yeah they're they're
gonna just be like people that like you
know isn't to the [__] you know like at
the end of pti where it's like you know
reali I mean um kornheiser and we'll
bond goal like they just spout and they
spout and it's like actually the Cubs
weren't like you know undefeated at home
this year like yeah they'll actually
lost like six games yes like it didn't
disprove your point but you know here's
the real I'm gonna have someone
hopefully do something like that that's
cool and then hopefully I'm gonna get my
English teacher to do like a because
sometimes I'll I want to do books where
I should have written like catcher in
the rye yeah and you know the great
gatsby it's great hello um I want to or
he Mele feel about the great pass it was
a great school I mean Thornton melon
exactly so did that guy look how far
that guy made it without reading so many
books he became an I would roll I hey
your thing all in fact and you're sure
nothing less give me that pen back
nobody was better than Rondo one but I
think you might want to look into being
because like I realized that I honestly
I don't know and I know this will sound
funny but I think I've just memorized
all these words it's very difficult for
me to reflux I come across a word that I
haven't seen before I'm like I don't
know I had a talk with David about that
ago how many times because my I used the
word recant incorrectly and he's like
it's actually recount and I was like no
recount means to go back and council and
he goes no it also means to go back and
say something and ago I go well that's
not what you said he goes I did say
Raquel you meant the other one where you
go back and count so we're both wrong
it's really funny that you mentioned dt
because i remember years ago i
recommended this book to David Taylor he
was like it is by far not literature it
is a quick Pope reduce yeah and I'll
tell you why it's not a good book and
then I was like hey man I related so
much to this book and it literally had
an impact on my life and you can't ask
for anything more out of the book and
it's so funny because that's my point of
this podcast is that everyone
that book we're like hey I think either
I don't know how you've made it this far
in life without reading this book or
this is something that affected me I did
a podcast with dave taylor and his book
with was heart of darkness then he read
high school and it is like again when i
go back to saying like it is one of
those stories where you know a narrators
going telling a story and it just gets
worse and worse and worse it's the movie
Apocalypse Now yeah yeah so I remember I
was supposed to have read that yeah well
that's what I said I go you read that in
high school he's like yeah and I go I
read Animal Farm in high school and he's
like yeah that's for like with the dumb
kids that we've assembled ISM for the
dumb kids yeah I had it on a deeper
level why I'm like yeah well that's you
shouldn't have read that you took that
too seriously you took that into the
world I read Machiavelli that Prince 9th
grade but I asked him how many times he
runs across words that he doesn't
understand he said it happens yeah but
for me yeah like I'll i have heard a
word said in its sentence in meaning
what I'm about to say to you in the same
meaning so I'm going to say the same
word but if you held me down do I know
what that word means not a hundred
percent no I do not and then I don't
know how to spell it spell it see that's
that like I saw an episode of The Cosby
Show in the 80s for Theo had dyslexia
and I made me convinced yeah she didn't
have it because like I thought dyslexia
meant if you said we're actually yes it
here's the thing about dyslexia nobody
has it the same way what do you mean
nobody has it the same way so how do you
test for something that there's all
these different questions and they can
get an understanding go into a gay
whole' of dyslexia test when I tell them
tonight and I was like oh that makes
sense now could i memorize everything I
know implants what people to sorry I
missed his couch it's the best it is a
good nap couch she absolute greatest and
you want to see something crazy I wasn't
going to tell you this story but it's
towards no one a hero now did look at
the book just open the front page oh no
is it goes their luck oh my god you got
it signed yeah it's the best story ever
how you got this on can I read what it
says yeah
Steve Simone don't lose your [__]
sense of humor Peter Farrelly and then
Bobby Farrelly glooming on underneath
it's hilarious Christmas 99 Oh da
Christmas on Christmas yeah listen to
this oh my god so 1999 this is now what
that's all 6 17 years ago yes you are i
graduated college okay 17 years ago I
was working for the Philadelphia Eagles
okay I had a dream job and part of my
responsibility was I was in charge of
all the game used equipment we would
sell it as collectibles it was awesome
mm-hmm so I loved my job so much I never
took any vacation time I was there I was
like cuz i started off working down
there for free with the cheerleaders and
the mascot as an intern yeah that's
where everyone starts work you write ins
like the mail room of the yes I like my
job is I'd have to call and get the
cheerleaders gigs and nobody ever did it
I was all like re home yeah i like i
like my wireless headset on pacing back
and people someone's going to buy a car
they're going to play a car with a
Philadelphia engineer leader standing
son sex into it yeah so there are very
it's great I want to get in sponsorships
for the mascot I got him free
Quicksilver clothes I got Metallica to
leave him a message to a video suite
like because I was so happy not to be
selling auto insurance is what it was so
by the time I got a job by 99 I had a
job job I never left what's the first
one in last one out because it was just
fun I was like the office mascot I'd
walk around and talk to everybody there
was this little old man named Danny who
would just come in and drink coffee and
read the paper didn't have a job there
he just hung out he was so adorable and
it was like meaning it would walk around
together it's just talked to real grown
ups that were working so I remember
during Christmas my boss is like dude
you're gonna lose your vacation time you
might as well take a day or two take
something so you don't lose it yeah
court and then my mom was like yeah it'd
be great why don't we go Christmas
shopping one day and I'm like okay so I
don't go to work one day I go Christmas
shopping with my mom and it's like
around this time
like a week before Christmas I remember
my mom going look I'm not going to ask
anything for Christmas I only want one
thing and you don't have to spend any
money I'm like what do you want she was
like I want you to tonight at st. John's
they're going to have priests from all
over to come in and do confessions she's
like one with the lesson even the
confession I was like I don't know when
confirmation like petrified I never once
those questions you're like should I lie
right now to you yes I was so scared is
it a sin if I lie right now you right
now exactly I ever might like that about
the truth by viruses I don't even
remember yeah so I did I went to
confession with my mom that night and I
remember this you know like will they
split up there's like ten preso over the
church and you just try to find and I'm
going where all the young people going
and I'm like I'll get behind I'll get
behind that guy in the jean jacket we
know Alex cursive English because we
know he's visiting so you could just say
whatever you want the best si si so I
remember I want that I was so nervous
and the priest was like love and X he
could tell that I was nervous asleep
relaxed kitchen son no so he just starts
talking to me and I'm not making this up
was like a scene out of a movie because
we're not my confessional you're like
sitting in a Pew face-to-face say when
they bring in all the priests Allah fire
so he's talking to me about stuff and
like really being super cool it would be
like going to confession to your brother
like a cool young priest that like gets
it and he just starts talking to me
about life like not about seeing or have
an inner just about life and then he
just stopped and he goes like this he
goes um I don't know why I'm telling you
this but I I feel like God wants you to
know this just you're gonna have a very
special life God has very
special things great things planned for
you and you should have nothing but joy
this holiday season I'm like okay we do
students to everyone exactly right so
then I go home I know my clone just felt
good you know exciting video action in a
while and he says something really nice
so then i'm such a nerd I'm checking my
voicemail from work that takes I'm one
cooler must work and there's a phone
number there's a voicemail from this guy
who's like I'm so-and-so I'm The Fairly
brother i'm peter farrelly system and
i'm lookin help me track down a
christmas gift and my phone number is
310 that the and I go 310 and never
disappear for really the internet we
didn't have it in our house it's 99 so I
take out a phone book I'm like 310 it
says it's Santa Monica it's Los Angeles
I'm like no way because I had already
I'd done a couple open mics by that
point and I already had my friends like
yeah this is Lauren Michaels especially
while you to call Saturday no lie Lauren
hey Lauren Lauren Michael yeah we seeing
you down at Barney's being so funny
drama thriller your head you want to
[__] me running into more in- hey it's
not Warren it's not a girl Kevin that's
Lauren so I really thought it was one of
my friends playing a goof on me but it
wasn't I called the number cuz it
three-hour time difference and the kids
like yeah we don't have a lot of money
but you know their agents from Philly do
you think maybe you could set them up
with something in this budget I got off
send it for free I'm such a big fan
they're like oh that's great and I go
yeah you know what they were like well
what can we send you and I'm like don't
worry about it there's just been so many
laughs Peter and Bobby have given me
through their movies I don't really want
anything in return they're like well
there's got to be something I got no
even more than the movies I go that
books a comedy writer changed my life I
go I loved it and I go wife and the kids
started laughing because you'll never
believe what I'm looking at I go what he
goes there's a box of unopened books
from the comedy writer right here he's
like how about if I get Peter to sign
one for you and I'm like yeah and he
sent me that and a crew jacket which I
lost but a jacket from me myself and
Irene
what's they had just finished filming
that's amazing amazing yeah well I think
that that priest had was correct yeah by
the way what to think about we've had an
amazing life you absolutely just being
out here the friends we've made it's
awesome I do also I mean look I have a
lot of west coast friends as I've opened
up more but the first group of people I
became close friends with here were
mostly East Coast people yes I think
that's necessary yep you know even when
the immigrants moved here yeah well
party to be do you for all they all
stayed together for a little bit and
then they spread out yes but we gotta
you know we stayed together for the
philly the New York the DC the Boston
yep it's true know for sure it was a big
contingent of our East Coast people well
I want to thank you for being on the
podcast I appreciate you taking the time
to go back and check the book out again
it's a great book I'm gonna read it can
I borrow it yes please I know I have
another copy around here somewhere too
but yeah do you have a good bobby
farrelly sign the other one now he
signed it 120 degree but it's great I
think you would enjoy it um yeah I like
narrative I like the narrator's style of
you know storytelling so yeah this is
great and plus you know we know that
world I'm super interested in it thank
you for being on the show and thanks for
having me the name of the book is the
comedy writer by Peter Farrelly
obviously you know the Farrelly Brothers
so you can check it out if you're
interested in reading it this was here
me this book thank you guys for
listening and we'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
I
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the Foundation's woodfield me a
buttercup don't break my heart from the
movies something about mary yeah that
was a good movie by the way I love that
film and I think it still holds up I
have to check it out thank you to Steve
Simone again for doing the podcast he
was fantastic the book was the comedy
writer by Peter Farrelly I want to take
a second to thank a few other people
Brian Stennis Stefan neck Stepanek come
on Steve Brian Stefan 'ok who does all
the photoshop posters for the podcast
when I released them he makes up the
poster and he's so good at it and I
thank him so check him out on Instagram
as well and then I got some great emails
this week from the podcast so thank you
if you want to email don't forget you
can email at hear me this book @
gmail.com again hear me this book at
gmail com I have a website Steve
Rannazzisi calm and very soon I will
have a link over 2 i'll get i'm putting
up i'm getting a page put together for
the for the podcast so soon i will have
the opportunity to you'll be able to
just go right to it from there but
specifically i wanted to mention this
guy where is he um where is the dude
that wrote me about he is all here it is
okay i don't want to give out his name
but he is quadriplegic and he was
commenting on what we were talking about
on the podcast you before me and
specifically he wrote to me because we
were wondering about whether
quadriplegics could get could get like
dude hard ons and things like that so he
wrote to me let me get this pull this up
he wrote to me this is what he wrote hey
man I don't know how to get in touch
with podcast guy before yes I get yes I
need to educate you about quadriplegics
yes I get boners yes I [__] hard but
autumn's are an issue since I can't
mentally control my boners the tightness
of the condom makes me lose my wood so I
don't want to use them unless she
insists and I use magnums so they aren't
that tight I [__] into my bed I sucked
in my chair is this with dr. Seuss book
by the way sorry I fooled around in the
shower so yes [__] still goes down and
everything works although I can't feel
it I usually make some grunting noises
like I would just would just so that
they feel like they're doing it well
laugh out loud oh man I love this guy so
guys guess what that's the answer to
whether or not quadriplegics have sex
and have intercourse and all that stuff
this guy's doing it all the time
something very healthy sex life and by
the way I think Katie who was on the
podcast with us once his number because
if all those things are true I think
she's down thank you guys again this is
hear me this book enjoy the rest of your
week and I'll see you next Tuesday
[Music]
Oh
Wow
[Music]
oh well but i love I mean you and Wonder
[Applause]
[Music]
I knew anyone
fear me and obey my heart
[Music]